let's talk about angel i love this
character
because i'm a fanatic for boxing movies
i just have
i've watched all of them even the most
cliche boxing movies and angel
is every boxer's
girlfriend so i think we've got some
good news for us well
you know tommy's fighting tonight so
i've been better
well i hope he wins yeah well i hope he
stays alive to see our kids grow up
so how many more hits till it's enough
were you going to fight at least no no i
told him
if he fights again i'm taking the kids
to my sisters
but where did this character come from
because again the specificity of your
characters
is you got like such a laser focus
it was really just uh it was when that
um
jake gyllenhaal rachel mcadams movie
came out southpaw
and i like i i heard a preview on the tv
for it
and you know she said something like you
know you think you're the fighter i'm
the fighter
and i was like wait i think amy adams
said that two years ago in the fighter
yes and then and then you just start
going through all
of them and it's the same scenes every
time and
i just got excited like maybe other
people
notice this too so just kind of hit on
that like
right at the right i felt lucky have you
um
because when i worked on starting out
live
a long time ago back when it was just a
puppet show um
but it was still we would have this
thing we would have to go in and pitch
ideas to lauren
and the uh performers on the show would
have to pitch
characters and it was hilarious because
i was
there when people pitched iconic
characters that went on to become these
huge staples
of starnette live i was there and
witnessed it but it was also there when
those same performers
pitched characters that went nowhere
yeah like john lovitz who of course
was known for so many great characters
uh
and i was there and he was convinced
he had this character who would uh
who would say you gotta get to know me
and then would take a drag on a
cigarette and say that's right get to
know me
and we all thought i don't know and then
he went to lauren he was like lauren
get to know me and laura was like
is there a character that you pitched
recently that just went nowhere
yeah like i i had um pitched and wrote a
woman who was
like a a voice over actress who uh
voiced all the hot dogs in the 80s and
it's like poodles and corgis and um
i really just thought like i was like
everyone's gonna get this like don't we
remember
like there were always those like hot
poodles
and um and it hasn't been on this season
so it will be
it's gonna get in there and it's going
to surprise everybody it's
going to be your character yet yes
you'll see and if that doesn't work
levitt's is old get to know me